I had this amazing acting teacher who's
passed away now named Roy London and
when I started working with him I went
for every every time I had an audition
for the toothpaste commercial I went to
him and one day he said to me what do
you really what's your real goal
I said I want to be able to sit across
from Robert De Niro and hold my own and
he's like that's your goal I'm like
that's my secret goal and the fact that
I got not in his lifetime unfortunately
but the fact that I got to do that wow
was everything to me and
the fact that I got to even audition and
to do that was such a big deal to me and
then when I got the part you know I
really hounded them to death to
really let me go for it and so I put my
all into it because it really was my
dream it's amazing you envisioned it and
it became reality I think ultimately